c'est au mit
on doit à max gallo historien et
romancier une dizaine de romans dont une
affaire intime et la baie des anges
il nous a reçus avec son chat opto 12
ans max gallo comment doit-on vous
définir romanciers essayistes
philosophes poètes romanciers ou
écrivains sont les deux termes qui me
convienne et que que j'assume vous êtes
en train de préparer quelque chose oui
j'ai un roman qui doit sortir dont je
relis les dernières dernière épreuve en
roman au titre paraîtra peut-être
ambitieux puisqu'il s'appelle france
vous êtes venu à la littérature comment
il me semble que j'ai toujours écrit
je crois que j'ai fait qu'une seule
chose dans ma vie de façon permanente
s'est tapé à la machine et votre notion
du bonheur
je suis heureux quand d'une certaine
manière je fais je participe à quelque
chose ou à une relation humaine avec
tellement d'intensité que j'oublie que
j'existe et avec les animaux quelles
sont vos relations avec les animaux vous
avez vu j'ai un chat et les chats sont
chez moi une une passion enfantine parce
que ya toujours eu des chats chez moi et
je crois qu'on s'habitue à un animal
quand on l'a connu dès l'enfance est
pour moi le chat est un animal idéal je
dirais idéal c'est presque une idée d'un
animal en fait tous ceux qui ont les
chats et qui les aiment savent que ce
sont des animaux secret fidèles jalons
excessif eux aussi dans l'eure dans
leurs relations
octo via auto bien qu'un mélange tiens
tiens octo voyez il est là il fait un
petit peu le beau mais je ne sais pas du
tout s'il viendra parce que ces lumières
les l'unc et bien octobre ya un mélange
bien il va te filmer tu être comme ça
vraiment une vedette une grande grande
vedette tu vas rester là bientôt sur mac
si vous êtes assez immobile il va peut
être acceptée parce que sinon ce qui est
intéressant dans dans les chasser c'est
leur orgueil seller le sorte de non et
puis leur individualisme si vous voulez
c'est ça qui est quand même la chose la
plus la plus extraordinaire pour moi
c'est cette sorte de liberté
ma mère qui achats évidemment qui est un
peu plus sauvage que celui ci dit
toujours et je crois que c'est vrai je
n'ai jamais vérifié que dans les cirques
on a vu toutes sortes d'animaux dressé y
compris des rats mais que des millions
bien sûr des éléphants mais que des
chats dressés
il y en a très peu et ça pour moi c'est
la vertu première
si vous voulez
du chat pourquoi octo ou au couteau
parce qu'il est né un mois d'octobre ce
qu'il faut dire que c'est le prince des
chats celui d'anne et d'ailleurs c'est
vrai parce qu'il est d'une très grande
tendresse et les chats les dires d'une
grande humanité froid là
opposant fait-il de travail et non parce
que c'est une présence à la fois sereine
donc apaisante et en même temps très
discrète dans un travail il ya des
moments nécessaires de presque de
distraction ou onex où on s'arrête où le
l'imagination travaille seul en silence
et où on est très content d'eux d'avoir
cette cette présence chaleureuse amis et
en même temps d'une d'une grande
discrétion
pourquoi un animal un animal surtout un
chat je parle du chat c'est une vérité
une liberté bien sûr en partie
socialiser parce que ce sont des animaux
domestiques
mais en même temps avec 700 aucune des
j'allais lire des exigences mais aussi
des masques de l'art que l'homme revêt
en sociétés par nécessité donc un animal
non dressés un peu domestique c'est vrai
mais qui comme un char est au fond une
liberté c'est la vie dans son
authenticité
c'est un peu comme une plante si vous
voulez même une plante en pot c'est
aussi l'avis est sceptique je crois que
c'est un peu pour ça qu'on voit
aujourd'hui les les gens dans nos
sociétés avoir de plus en plus d'animaux
et de plus en plus de plantes la vivrai
il a livré des gens et leurs visages
vrai devient de si rare et ce masque si
souvent qu'on a envie de pouvoir avoir
un animal est ce que vous comptez écrire
sur les animaux âge
je crois qu'il y a de plus en plus
d'animaux dans les romans que j'ai écrit
avec une sans que je le veuille parce
que je crois qu'on ne maîtrise pas
toujours ce que l'on dit est ce que l'on
écrit c'est une sorte d'inconscient qui
parle avec de plus en plus dans ses
livres par exemple dans france dans
celui d'avant une affaire intime avec
des animaux qui ont une sorte de
fonction symbolique parce que je crois
que les animaux sont aussi des des
récepteurs de ce qui se passe par
exemple je crois que un chat son humeur
son caractère sa façon d'être dépendent
beaucoup de qui vite avec lui chasse à
ça capte et si vous êtes avec le ch
appartient à une personne anxieuse et
bien le chat est anxieux ou au contraire
il est paisible alors il faut croire
qu'en ce moment je suis assez paisible
puisse cocteau est assez paisible et
donc je crois que l'écrivain un jour
pour répondre très précisément à votre
question et tu as menée et je serai
amené peut-être à écrire sur un animal
en faire le centre d'une histoire parce
que je crois que l'animal en relation
avec l'homme cet autre étrange animal
eh bien je crois que un animal rassemble
et symbolise toutes les forces les plus
secrètes de la vie